i believe in freedom of speech i believe
in the right to
be allowed to have an opinion if people
want to believe meghan markle
that's entirely their right i don't
believe almost anything that comes out
of her mouth
piers morgan is speaking out after
abruptly quitting
good morning britain i think the damage
he's done to the british monarchy
and to the queen at a time when prince
philip is lying in hospital
is enormous and frankly contemptible
so if i have to fall on my sword for
expressing an honestly held opinion
so be it on tuesday the 55 year old
journalist
made the decision to leave the morning
show after viewers
and his own co-host alex biersford
slammed him for comments about meghan
markle
following her tell-all sit-down with
oprah winfrey
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue
to trash her okay i'm done with this no
no sorry no
do you know what that's pretty cool
maybe not mine no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no i'm being
sorry absolutely diabolical behavior
the feeling to piers is quite simple
over here in britain
he's a bit like marmite too you either
love him or you hate him
but pierce he dishes it out he's got to
be able to take it too
i think there was quite a lot of
surprise when he took his mic
off and stormed out the studio today
after getting a bit of a talking to you
or addressing down
from his weatherman later that day itv
released a statement announcing piers's
decision to leave the morning program
and not long after he took to twitter to
share this picture with his late manager
writing quote
he'd have told me to do exactly the same
thing
adding trust your gut got a good chat
with itv and
we agreed to disagree of course this all
comes after piers received
a lot of backlash for questioning the
duchess of sussex's claims
of struggling with mental health and
suicidal thoughts
during her pregnancy with her son archie
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle
i wouldn't
against our royal family i think is
contemptible after pierce quit the show
he doubled down and stood by his
previous sentiment tweeting quote
on monday i said i didn't believe meghan
markle in her oprah interview
i've had time to reflect on this opinion
and i still don't
if you did okay freedom of speech is a
hill i'm happy to die
on thanks for all the love and hate i'm
off to spend more time with my opinions
i wish them all the very best had a
great time at good morning britain
good morning britain has become the most
watched
talked about show argue beyond british
television i mean the ratings on monday
were the biggest we've ever had we also
got the most of com complaints
for any show we've done because people
didn't like my opinion
um that's a hill i'm prepared to go on
but now reports claim
megan might have been involved in
pierce's decision
to leave the show which he joined in
2015.
according to multiple reports the 39
year old former suit star
lodged a formal complaint with itv in
response
to pierce's comments about her mental
health cnn reports that megan's
complaint was about the
impact his comments could have on others
and how it could degrade the seriousness
of mental health issues
piers has had a lot of stick over
um what many i think perceived to be his
relentless bashing of harry and megan
and you'll see if you follow him on
twitter
friends just will often tweet just leave
them alone what piers is an argument is
no
they don't want to be left alone they're
putting themselves in the public eye
and you know i'm gonna go for them and
he and he has done repeatedly
as for pierce on wednesday he told his
fans
not to worry about him i think it's fair
to say although the
woke crowd would have thought they think
that they've cancelled me
i think they'll be rather disappointed
when i re-emerge
so a re-emergement i would call it a
temporary hibernation but
of course my opinions remain my opinions
they can't silence that